okay dass der schweiß aus aber wir
wollen ein anderes hintergrundbild wie
wäre es mit und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute geht es wieder
rund mit dem murphy bord und wir legen
direkt los hier sehen wir noch die
errungenschaften das letzte bob marley
featuring fucking und wenn ich sage dann
nicht weil ich nicht mag oder so sondern
einfach weil es so abwegig ist cook ist
einfach an
guckt euch einfach dieses ding an der
matif erklärung für dieses bild war das
bob marley so hart gekämpft hat dass
simon uns geist erschienen ist aber nur
der teil seines gesichts deswegen das
steht für geist logischerweise und
dieser geist aus bob marleys körper
entwichen ist
so oder so wir legen los heute direkt
mit einer knackigen saftigen kombination
und zwar wird das geht glaube ich auch
also was wenn k s creek einen langen
bart hätte oh ja er macht was er macht
was er macht was
dagegen war für gesicht was ist das das
ist eine faschingsmaske mit keine ahnung
dann darf dem grauen kombiniert dk
murphy bord was mit ihr los als irgend
einer von euch eine ahnung welches wesen
da als käfig genommen wurde so wenn wir
jetzt nämlich hier einen traurigen
smiley rein tippen dann weist der report
dass das den like it change the photo
heißt also quasi gibt uns ein neues bild
problem jetzt mal aus junge murphy das
ist ein fucking anonymous pascal das ist
nicht alles klar leute im internet 2016
berief youtuber 2016 das liebe leute ist
es seine wahre identität das erstmal
gucken können wir auch irgendwie das
gesicht verändern was er unser tag
trauriger smiley und face trauriger
smiley und face robot letzte chance um
zu beweisen dass du nicht vollkommen tal
bis
das ist schon mal besser aus alter das
sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus oder
ich finde das sogar ziemlich gut so die
übergänge sind mega heiß gemacht
eigentlich ich will noch mal ein anderes
hintergrund foto habe ich wieder mal so
ein richtig richtig langen bart haben
kommen wir die mir richtig lang war erst
das richtige gesicht im bad
wenn sie sagt dass sie auf let's play
offs figur sapporo wisst ihr was apa/red
wäre langweilig wir machen wir machen so
ein bisschen transgender so eine kleine
geschlechter vermischung von fps frames
katja kasan zeigen sein videos und leute
meint natürlich natürlich fingert sich
katja auf ihrem youtube ps und ist nackt
überrascht und roter falls auch down
roter kreis und noch weiter fall aber
bitte nur kurz darauf eingehen ich finde
es sieht aus wie die wii oder diese auf
eine seltsame weise sieht das aus wie
drückt euch dieses gesicht ist überhaupt
erst ins gesicht hat er so ein
leberflecken am mundwinkel wollen der
das tue wenn sie dir sagt dass wir nicht
auf youtube player steht das ist eine
reaktion aus dem echten leben nie voll
geständig war ich gehen club okay ich
sehe mädel auf der tanzfläche was was
ganz neues ist ihr wisst schon
interessante persönlichkeit und dann
sagte mir einfach dass hier nicht auf
micro flash player steht und dann
verschiebt sich mein gesicht einfach so
nach rechts aber durchaus vorstellen
es gibt aber mein gesicht zu nach rechts
schaut übrigens meine kleine schwester
die gerade klavier spielt okay dass der
fasching als neues aus aber wir wollen
ein anderes hintergrundbild wie wäre es
mit das beste bild dass youtube 2016 die
wahrheit wird auf so vielen
verschiedenen ebenen aufgedeckt hier
catherine ist eigentlich ein muss maske
und castries bisherige youtube realität
ist einfach katja gasser witches rechte
dieses bild ist so falsch auf so vielen
verschiedenen ebenen im gesicht wenn du
merkst du eigentlich gar kein mensch
sondern hat der krasse witches rechte
titel bist weil ich lieber mal für das
zocken leute ja es macht sich eigentlich
ganz gut hier so mit den mädels würde
ich sagen deswegen will ich mal sagen
jfks trikot als uci kat mal gucken ob er
dafür bekommt wetten
er nimmt eine richtige katze robert ich
habe richtig sprechen
mein gott
okay leute schnell weiter dass das ist
eine amerikanische szene gesetzten
youtuber das team star ja der hat halt
keine ahnung hat und ist nicht so mega
groß und dass sie wieder von einem
genannt also gnome ja und ich möchte
einfach ausprobieren sturni verzeiht mir
das ist nicht böse absicht wolfsturm
waffe wars gartenzwerg ich hoffe jetzt
wenn jemand drei dich ich muss es
einfach ausprobieren oder bei dem leben
von crafter lama wobei lama erwarte
nicht lama computer-hacker ich habe
jetzt nicht oder nr packer weil ich
keine ahnung aber das steckt schon jetzt
auch ein alpaka oh ja leute das ist es
gut durch so ein wunderschönes tier
seht euch einfach diese majestätische
kreaturen es ist das fucking lose packe
voll in dieser blick diese
hoffnungsvolle blick das lose packer
schaut einfach so in die ferne schaut
auf die zukünftigen youtube millionen
schaut auf alles was bevorsteht und ihr
seht
er freut sich als klug für heute wir
haben gelacht wir haben geweint wir
haben gesehen wie sich youtuber in tiere
verwandeln haben gesehen als freak hat
der casa wirtschaftsmächte titel ist
müssen wir noch mehr wissen in diesem
sinne haut rein macht es gut wenn sich
gefallen hat was gern leichter und
schreibt man die kommentare wir diese
marke bot videos findet dass du mich
interessieren
bis dann haut rein macht's gut und ja